what brings you here tonight then we're
here to support the independent film
today Eric my publicist and check it out
and have a good time well so many people
seem Project Runway what do you think
the public doesn't know about the
fashion industry we know it to be maybe
cutthroat but what are some surprises
that might actually be positive things
that the public isn't aware of with a
fashion industry about the bath industry
in general um I think there are a lot of
collaborations going on right now in the
industry that I think makes fashion one
more exciting where creative minds could
get together with other cultures like
India I've been talking to some indian
suppliers using some of the textiles and
designs in my line so that will also
bring you know my products to another
level will bring a new element to it so
i think that's something that's
happening now fashion that i'm really
excited about of all time what's the
best model who knows how to sort of wear
it well and it has sort of I mean for me
I thought gia was the best model I
thought she was just she had this thing
where she was just there was like a
duality tour what about you who's of
your favorite models little bit want I
can't even answer that question oh yeah
I don't know why they might be listening
oh yeah maybe there may be there from
the past you don't have to tell them now
so they're not modeling anymore
you know what that's a tough question i
really would have to think about a
little more princess grace all right
Thank You Becky sure you're welcome